i get a call from barry gesser
barry gesser's jordan belford's
right-hand man this was my first direct
association as you know a businessman
with the mob and i got a call from
my mother
who told me that the fbi had just come
to the house wanting to talk to me what
kind of money were you making at the
time i'm making probably 50 000 a month
in 88 you're making 50. and i beat that
car from beginning to end
from
from the sides to the windows to the
mirrors i had an early nickname where i
was the guff meaning i took no guff from
nobody because i guess i was
compensating for my size always trying
to prove myself be good with my hands
this is probably going to be a different
angle of the mafia mob interview
uh but you can appreciate this one
because i'm sitting with a man who at
one point in 2003 went away for a
hundred million dollars
stock scam but if you take him back when
he was working with the gambino family
back in the days the way he got started
was with a firm called jd
fd roberts securities which he used to
compete with the name you may know
jordan belfort from wolf of wall street
and he went from there to working with
the gambino family to working with mikey
scars
at a year where the senate subcommittee
talked about the mob was
getting somewhere around 10 billion
dollars from the stock market from the
stock market
he hasn't done any interviews except for
one from uk with trevor mcdonald this is
his first long-form interview he's doing
he's wanted to be low-key for a specific
reason so with that being said sal
romano thank you so much for being a
guest somebody today my pleasure patrick
so i read your wikipedia i read the
articles no interviews except for trevor
mcdonald the one you do with uh you know
the mafia woman the wives and children
all that stuff why have you not done an
interview with anybody
oh i mean that being said it's not
something that i'm proud of nor do i
really want to talk about it i still
have family members but you know with me
it's about controlling the narrative a
little bit so i don't like the way i'm
portrayed in some areas or some respects
so it's probably a good time in my life
now to possibly talk about it
sounds good so you know why don't we go
back just walk us through how you
came up the streets and how you got
connected with fd roberts and how you
got into the securities industry tell us
your story sure uh i was born in
bensonhurst brooklyn i know most of the
wise guys you talk to are
and uh
after that we moved to staten island
which literally you know everybody goes
from from brooklyn to staten island
ultimately jersey and then they migrate
to other areas so i was raised in staten
island an area called new springville a
lot of big mafia influence there you had
sammy the bull gravano you had frankie
de chico you had sonny saccone you had a
lot of you know
wise guys that came from brooklyn and
moved to staten island so it was always
in front of us it was always there it
was always you know looking at the cars
and the jewelry and the money and the
power so it was always in front of us it
was a way of life for us
and did you see everybody like did you
see sammy and did you see them yes i
mean i was a little kid but yeah of
course we saw them and they were a great
influence on us plus the distance
between staten island and brooklyn it's
like 20 minutes so we were always in
brooklyn my family remained in brooklyn
so we were just always around it it was
always
in front of us what was the reputation
like what reputation did the ma i mean
we've obviously we've seen many
different versions stories what was the
reputation even as a kid who was sammy
who was the chief who who were these
guys in the streets it goes back long
before sammy you know with my family it
was carlo gambino and paul castellano
what happened was my grandfather on my
mother's side who's a legitimate
business a legitimate butcher
and he came to this country in the 30s
and he was sponsored by carlo gambino
and paul castellano so ultimately they
end up bankrolling him in a few butcher
shops in harlem when there was a strong
mob influence and italian influence in
harlem so he had butcher shops and he
was a butcher and i don't remember him
ever mentioning carlo to me but it was
always big paul ben paul you've always
met you got it so my mom was sicilian my
dad was uh from nate uh his family was
from naples so i was half knobbly down
the half sicilian
and
growing up in brooklyn my father you
know as a kid was always in a gang
so he was very good with his hands he
was a muscular guy
oh yeah he was definitely a genuine
tough guy but he was also very educated
so he preached education to his children
so he had the best of both worlds he was
very smart he was an accountant and he
was good with his hands so everything
with him was making sure his children
were educated and could handle ourselves
physically and i was never the biggest
or the strongest but i always thought of
myself as being very tough i was always
fast i never backed down to a fight i
had an early nickname where i was the
guff meaning i took no guff from nobody
because i guess i was compensating for
my size always trying to prove myself be
good with my hands
and we were always exposed to it so my
dad had always done business with wise
guys as their accountant he had card
games he was always a [ __ ] a book
maker so frankie dico was always in my
home when i was a kid and he was a
powerhouse so with us forget about
queens and gotti and anything that was
going on in jersey or the west side with
the genovese it was always the gambino
family and it was always in front of us
so that being said my father got me a
job at lehman brothers in 1985. and this
is before it was shearson before it was
american express this is when lehman
brothers was the preeminent investment
banking firm in the world you would make
a cold call and tell a prospect you were
calling from lehman brothers
but with that being said i saw all the
improprieties that were going on even
there because at the time we didn't even
have fax machines so there was no way to
get news so what lehman brothers would
do or any other brokerage firm for that
matter is they'd sell a stock let's say
ten dollars and they'd print fourteen
they'd make four dollars a share on it
so finra at the time was the nesd they
then you know started implementing the
five percent markup rule but back then
there was no rule so you would sell a
client
wow what a time to be in it's the best
time an asd that's right so you would
sell a client today and tomorrow they
wouldn't know where it was trading until
they ultimately opened up the new york
times and saw a quote in the newspaper
so they don't they wouldn't even realize
how overpaid they paid
and you know that's when you know
statements like if you can't net it
forget it and churn them and burn them
that was all lehman brothers in you know
the seventies they didn't get away with
it at that time though limited
regulation
got it so the regulation was extremely
necessary obviously without a doubt okay
without a doubt got it and that being
said that was wayward lehman three years
okay and that was my first exposure to
this what a way to start though yeah but
it just looked like the norm not the
exception it looks like this is the way
wall street business is done
so that being said i left there after
three years and i worked for a small
firm in manhattan called steinberg and
lyman which essentially was mostly
healthcare venture capital and i got
exposed to that and i studied and i
learned as much as i could about the
investment banking side because that's
the side i always wanted to be in
after i left there
me and my group went looking for a firm
we saw an advertisement the local
newspaper for a firm out in new jersey
and i went there
they were promoting penny stocks i had
never even heard of a penny stock
but what impressed me was the money they
were making for their clients
they were showing like 200 percent
returns on their recent ipos clients
were making money had no idea the
quality of the company i mean how good
can a company be if it's trading at
pennies a share
so that being said i signed on to work
with them jordan that you mentioned was
already an employee there
and you know everybody that worked there
was absolutely clueless they were all
young they were all uneducated they were
none of them had the experience i had so
it was so easy for me to rise in the
ranks being from lehman brothers having
the pedigree in the background and the
training that i received was second to
none got it so within 90 days i became
assistant branch manager which i wanted
because they gave me an extra 5 000 a
month for
and within five months i became the
branch manager so that was the position
that was coveted and three or four guys
jockeyed for it and one of them was
jordan had very little interaction with
him but i thought he was a nice guy and
this is before i think any of his vices
or anything but he was a good salesman
what impressed me and what stood out is
that he was head and shoulders above
everybody else there he was
he was terrific in what way in what way
the way he carried himself his
professionalism his knowledge of the
market and his salesmanship who was he
with before you were with the lehman but
who did he come from i have no idea okay
i know nothing about his past up until
that got it and so were you guys
competing against each other or no you
could say that in other words what the
firm tried to say is in order to get the
promotion they would go with who they
felt was the most qualified but it
really came down to production because
the last thing
upper management wanted to do was lose a
rep that could take those positions to
another firm and then ultimately sell
those positions and drive the stock down
so i had by far the greatest position in
the firm and i was you know by far the
most talented but the separator between
me and everybody else was a nobody was
gonna outwork me and nobody was gonna
out study me including jordan yeah i
mean
jordan was far away this was northern
new jersey and jordan i don't know if he
lived in long island or westchester but
he had a long commute so i don't think
he was going to put in the hours that i
was going to put it out she got a party
together no no no nothing like that you
guys were in the same office together we
were yeah we were two feet from each
other get out of here so you're hearing
him on the calls as well yeah he was
talented he was a good guy
so
script if you're calling me what was a
conversation like with the client what
do you what are you telling the client
what was the script like patrick you and
i had a conversation going back about a
month ago i told you i would only
contact you if we had something
exceptional if you noticed in the recent
newspaper our returns have been over 150
on our ipos although i don't have an ipo
for you today i have something really
exciting if you have a couple minutes
i'd like to share with you sure and then
you get it
now the separator is i'm going to do
that 400 times a day i'm going to get
there at 7 45 in the morning and i'm not
leaving until nine ten o'clock at night
so i'm gonna out study you and i'm gonna
outwork you if i don't know my product
i'm the worst salesman in the world if i
know my product there's nobody what kind
of money were you making at the time i
mean again it's 1988 and i'm making
probably fifty thousand a month in
eighty-eight you're making fifty i'm 21
years old it's a lot of money in it
you're 21 years old what's life like are
you have you started partying or not yet
i'm still living at home i'm a kid
the partying thing wasn't that important
to me because me and my wife who's my
wife now
uh we've been together since i was 17.
so i was already on my way to you know
trying to get focused on getting engaged
and having a family so partying wasn't
important to me establishing the career
was primary 37 years you've been
together with your wife that's correct
that's unbelievable four children that's
incredible ranging in age from 26 to
nine holy moly good so you're still
working good for you hard working family
so you're making 50 a month you're 21
you're not a party guy you're staying
home you and your wife you've been
together since 17 you know you become
the branch manager five months later
you're you're doing your thing jordan
leaves he resides at that okay so go
from there jordan leaves there's a mass
exodus at that point now the mob
influence that was there was a legendary
gambino gangster by the name of joe
butch correa
who was working there no of course not
he's a major gangster but the firm is on
record with him okay so the way it went
down is there are two principles of the
firm their names were freddie gagliardo
and johnny perfetti
and the two of them the way they dressed
the way they looked the way they carried
themselves you could see gangster
personification
so this was my first direct association
as you know a businessman with the mob
although it's been an influence in me
since i'm a baby now it's directly with
me and i'm running the show here so what
happens is the security regulators ban
them from the industry so they get asked
to leave this is fd roberts yes okay so
after they stepped down a fella down
here in florida by the name of lenny
tucker
legendary trader he steps in as chairman
and he's the one that promotes me the
branch office matters so fd roberts
stays intact yeah except the people that
were involved with the mob they step
away they had to they were banned for
the industry got it okay and i guess the
prerequisite was the firm to remain open
if those two fellows step away makes
sense so joe butch carrajo's son vincent
was an employee there the day i met him
i said what do you do for a living big
guy too he shows his business card he
said assistant to the chairman of the
board i said okay
so i looked at this i said i'm gonna
take this place over this is mine i'm
italian nobody can work like i do nobody
knows this industry like i do this was
built for me i had one requisite and
that's i want to open up in lower
manhattan i want to be on wall street so
ultimately we do open up on wall street
we were there two months the feds raided
the place the place was closed down and
that was the end of that so the whole
thing lasted maybe 14 15 months so the
50k my last 14 15 months at 21. did you
do time or no no no i was not party to
any any criminal liability because my
time there we had done no initial public
offerings no ipos at that time were you
licensed are you serious i was like okay
i got my license there you got your
license at ft roberts okay so you go to
lower manhattan you're you want your
branch couple months later boom what
happens next we're overlooking the
hudson we had the most gorgeous office
we were ready to rock and roll and then
it ended when it did end
i was skiing up in hunter mountain in
upstate new york
and i got a call from
my mother
who told me that the fbi had just come
to the house wanting to talk to me
telling her tell your son to get home
immediately is going to be indicted this
is for fd roberts i get an attorney i go
to two gateway plaza in newark new
jersey and i walk in there are three fbi
agents two agents for the securities
exchange commission two from the nasd
two postal inspectors
and two representatives from new jersey
bureau securities so they get me in this
room and they corner me asking me to
wear a wire to testify against freddie
gagliardo joe butch correao johnny
perfetti and i said am i being charged
today with anything and they said no i
said conversation's over got up walked
out never heard another word so it was a
bluff i called him out on the bluff and
i was fine so next after i leave fd
roberts
and this is where jordan and i are
passed across again interesting enough
if you if you looked at a breakdown of
my securities license you'll see after
fd roberts there were two other firms
that i signed on for as i signed on both
of them subsequently closed within days
of me going there so i said okay i'm
done with the small firms i'm going back
to the big firms there was a major wall
street firm been around 100 years called
gruntal gruntal at the time was the
third largest insurance company in the
world insurance company yes but they had
a broken dealer got it so i went to work
in an office there i get a call from
barry gesser
barry gesser's jordan belford's
right-hand man
at oak at stratton or i didn't know at
the time
but i believe it was stratton security
it's owned by a fellow by the name of
jim taramina
barry calls me cesaro what are you doing
you're at gruntal are you crazy
gruntle's like merrill lynch you can't
own merrill lynch
let me tell you what i'm doing you
remember jordan so i said yeah he said
okay i'm buying stratton securities
jordan's buying a company called oakmon
out in long island we're going to merge
the companies we want you to own we want
you to run the manhattan operation with
the possibility of being national sales
manager i said let me come meet you i
drive into manhattan he's working at i'm
sorry he's living at trump park which
made an impression on me who's he jordan
is barry gesser i never see jordan nor
do i talk to him and i never did to this
day so i drive to trump park barry's in
his apartment i walk in and i said barry
there's no way in the world you're
getting me this early unless you pay me
up front he says what do you want i said
35 000 cash up front he says done meet
me at the office tomorrow we'll go over
all the terms i went there i signed an
agreement he gave me the check i said
i'll start on monday i deposited the
check in those days checks took forever
to cash
ultimately i start on monday on tuesday
to check bounces
i says barry you got to be kidding me
man how do you let this check bounce i
mean i'll leave in three seconds you got
to make good on this
ultimately he gives me another check or
i redeposit it i don't remember it
bounces again now he's with jordan in an
office in long island i drive there like
a raving lunatic
and i'm banging on doors nobody will see
me nobody will talk to me i take a bat i
go under the building into the garage
where his little red mercedes
convertible is and i beat that car from
beginning to end from
from the sides to the windows to the
mirrors and just destroyed the car
left and never again heard from bearing
yes i wrote jordan belford again as i
was said and i had no dealings with
jordan there only barry
that's literally the story that is the
truth okay 1989. so 89 at this point so
the 35 000 check bounces twice
you go destroy car they go on to merge
stratton oakmont and then become
stratton oakmont securities they've
blown up yet has jordan blown up here i
don't even to be honest with you i don't
even know and i'm not bad mouthing
anybody and i'm not starting any fights
i i've never even heard of that i don't
even know what they did it wasn't like
you know the most popular firm on the
street they were buried in long island
doing their thing you know but the wolf
of wall street i don't know anything
you've seen a movie though yeah of
course okay so you didn't know nothing
about the stories of the parties any of
that stuff no but that was the norm that
was going on but you were not on the
scene either so it's not like you were
in the same party and because you were
more a guy that was a married guy my
office was okay i got you once i blew up
and did my thing like we did the [ __ ]
bowling
that was you yeah but whether or not he
did it too i can't tell you whether he
did i remember a couple of my guys heard
it on howard stern because howard stern
had the [ __ ] polar so they they had a
party one day in the office and they did
it and i remember that
the dwarfs with the helmets on they kept
banging into the elevator so these guys
were all crazy so i was around it i just
didn't encourage it promoted it or
participate emotionally but you guys did
it all of them did it yeah we had a we
got a what was it what would you you pay
these men you pay them to do it like you
how does that work it's like hey there
was a 200 bucks to there was a service
that provided this that's a business
model
what a stranger promoting it it was a
strange business model okay so again not
to say jordan wasn't real but yeah
whether you want to say the book of the
movie was you know
i don't know
there's footage of this guy partying
like a madman and there's a lot of i'm
sure they did yeah so so by the way i i
watched the movie
uh in sherman oaks at the arclight
theater with my dad sitting all the way
in the back my dad was cracking up for
two and a half straight hours i said
what'd you think about the movie great
movie i'm like okay dad
obviously the critics agreed because it
was an academy award nominated i mean
and obviously you have the lead guy if
you're going to have anybody playing the
lead it's it's not bad when you have the
leo playing the level of course and
scorsese yeah that's right little time i
spent with him i i liked him a lot he
was a very likable guy and there were no
vices at the time you know sometimes
that comes later you've got to be
patient bites to show up what do i know
about a guy that wants to do drugs and
i know nothing about it sure i've never
done a drug in my life so that's not
your world you're not one dad no getting
married early probably helped you out
from not getting in too much trouble
yeah i mean i i guess yeah one of the
things that helped me is i had no vices
none i like to gamble but i like to
casino gamble and i never gambled over
my head plus i had the money i never
sports gambled never did drugs didn't
you know do the women thing so it just
wasn't in my you know universe which
kept me clean makes sense okay so what
happens next so this is going to have my
own okay so now it's 1989 okay and i
opened up one of the first franchise
operations of a brokerage firm so with
that being said it's like opening up a
subway i didn't own the broker dealer
but i owned the franchise they're 22 or
23 22. 22 years old you open up your own
place how many that is called financial
equity resources i hooked up with an
investment banker in philadelphia by the
name of howard appel who was absolutely
brilliant and this was my foray into
investment banking this is how i learned
to do investment banking like today they
call them spax
special purpose acquisitions right
corporations back then it was blind
pools so we can raise money off a strong
management team and then go look for the
acquisition and then ultimately that
became the reverse merger play and we
were the kings of it but the blind pool
did it have as bad of a reputation as
spax do today or no it was too early to
have any bad news
nobody knew anything about it the first
one we did is you may know the guy a
fellow by the name of wayne allen root
no okay he was like an early sports
prognosticator a brilliant guy he's got
you know he's got his blogs and his
youtube thing going he's pretty famous
now but at the time it was it was sports
prognostication
and that was the first blind pool we did
got it so so 22 years old you start your
own place you start doing uh blind pools
you get the management team first you
get the money and then you go find a
business on what you guys want to do
what happened we're doing a lot of
reverse mergers but we're doing quality
deals okay and i think that's what kept
me underneath what were the deals how
big were the deals you're doing no that
was small deals you know the way you
would normally work if you want me to
give you a little lesson or for your
viewers just understand what a reverse
merger is the publicly traded company is
there first and what that publicly
traded company is is a company that's
been stripped down it might have filed
chapter 11 it might just be a depressed
stock that's now trading at pennies a
share so what we would do is we would
let's say seek a company looking for
financing so you come to me and you say
sal i need 10 million dollars in cash we
would tell you well we're not just going
to give you 10 million dollars without
having an already inherent exit strategy
can we explain to you how to go public
or that we could take you to work once
you're buying in on that we'll use our
own cash maybe give you a million bucks
in cash just to hold you over and then
we'll use that money or other money
additional capital to buy that publicly
traded company because it's trading at
.001 cents a share and there's 50
million shares out there which cost us
nothing so once we've bought and seized
control of that publicly traded company
we're now taking that first emerging the
operating entity into it taking the
company public hence the words reverse
merger the public entity is there first
now we have as much as twenty thirty
forty percent of that stock
that the ceo and his management team has
whatever twenty thirty forty percent you
have ten fifteen twenty percent of the
already existing shareholders and you
create that merger now the investment
banking work comes in if the stock's
trading at a penny you may want to do a
reverse split make a trade at a dollar
if it's trading at a dollar make it
trade a 10 sure but now we have paper
all of that is legal
the illegality part is as the public is
buying we're selling
and in order to do that we have to let's
say promote
that stock which is still okay but it's
the additional compensation given to a
licensed stock broker in the form of a
cash payment under the table where he no
longer has his investors best interest
at heart but lining his own pockets and
that's the illegal part who else was
doing that at the time everybody okay so
even the bigger guys we're doing well i
don't know about the bigger guys but
there's always been additional
compensation i'll give you an example
and this is the way lehman
qualified it they used to be soft dollar
deals so the way lehman used to work is
when they used to get a syndication and
this indication is for let's say a
company going public they're doing a hot
ipo and everybody knows it's going to be
a hot ipo so ultimately what they would
do is they would get a syndication or a
set amount based on their production so
if patrick was one of the best brokers
he's going to get a hundred thousand
shares of this ipo
now there are
traders out there that covet that want
that need your ipo
now they can't compensate you so what
they do is they give you an american
express card and they say enjoy yourself
take your wife on vacation go to the
bars go to the strip joints whatever it
is we got and there is the soft dollar
deal as it's called got it so that form
or
let's say the practice has been around
forever
it's got different names and and maybe a
different methodology but the practice
itself has been around forever they're
not doing it today anymore though right
how do i know yeah i mean i never talk
about things i don't know yeah finra's
uh
they
did they have the gift limitation back
in the days to clients or did they have
a hundred dollar deal
yeah yeah by the way we were talking
about yesterday with a guy who's a
doctor talking about opioids how these
doctors are making all this money
because these big pharma companies are
giving
uh uh you know whining and dying on
these doctors i said if finra gave us a
hundred dollar limit for client maybe
the pharmaceutical industry needs to
have a gift limit that they're giving
their doctors but anyways that's a
complete
different conversation it's difficult to
go after big pharma it is tough nowadays
that's why you know they're doing what
they're doing anyways going back to this
so you're you're 20 to 23
you're you're running your shop you're
doing these blinds it's a very small
shop i got four or five guys okay i got
two so walk me through what happens next
you're doing these deals now this is
where the plot thickens for me so now
i'm making some money decent money more
than more than fd yeah on certain
occasions i am yeah but it's mostly with
the undisclosed additional commissions
100 a month
yeah some months even more okay it
depends so you're making a mill a year
yeah absolutely so now at this point
somebody approaches me and wants me to
finance their
finance company it's it's like an
advanced fee loan business
so i look at it i do my due diligence
it's 100 legitimate i agree to bankroll
them
when i do
i throw my dad in there to watch my
investment he's retired at this point so
he's working there and i throw my sister
in there to answer the phones so i have
enough coverage in there or at least i
take solace that they know what they're
doing
so ultimately this becomes a criminal
operation in other words overzealous
sales reps using their fake names
charging advance fees upfront so i'm not
a participant in it i don't contribute
to it but at the end of the day i'm as
guilty as they are the money's going to
be sure
so i'm i'm a participant in this so with
that i think we receive something like
900 inquiries at the better business
bureau in 1990
okay so that encourages and precipitates
a postal service investigation into the
firm i give an interview to the local
paper they knew it was coming i
explained to them nothing is
more valuable to me than the integrity
of my firm my integrity uh what they're
accusing of is wrong so on and so forth
ultimately i get indicted my dad gets
indicted my sister gets indicted very
clever on that part because my sister
although she's just answering the phone
is now a party to a conspiracy which
means if i go to trial i'll beat this in
three seconds
but am i going to risk her and now now i
have a problem so i ultimately have to
plead guilty that guilty plea is going
to give me a mandatory jail sentence one
and number two it's going to ban me from
ever working on wall street again
so i agree i plead guilty
sometime in 92
and in 1993 i started three-year
sentence in morgantown west virginia
this is the 30 months that you got
correct okay got it so now when i get
there i'm in morgantown west virginia
my father's there with me
and if i can be 100 honest i'm having
the time of my life
this was
this was like almost an organized crime
training camp for me
because all the gangsters are there
everybody's talking about their war
stories they're talking about this and
there were some big guys that it was the
jackalone family from detroit
and my buddy jackie is now the boss of
the detroit partnership
dead there guys from pittsburgh uh
youngstown ohio steubenville ohio a
couple of guys from new york so you know
if you look at every crew let's see the
colombians are three or four guys puerto
ricans and three or four guys darian
brotherhood of three or four guys we
were like 40 strong
having the time of our life
so this is supposed to discourage me
when i arrive back home i mean if if the
fear is prison
you could take that element out of my
life
and i'm the kid i'm the baby they all
love me i'm carrying things for them i'm
helping them yeah everybody called me
the kid the kid that was pretty popular
it was well liked and we had a ball
so now i get released and i say to
myself okay what's my next move so
before my release i'm doing about six
months worth of research trying to
figure out what my next gig is
and it looks like the head the hottest
sector right now
due to the breakup of the baby bells is
long-distance phone service it looked
like like you could make big money in
commissions distance phone service are
you talking like excel communication
cards because the baby bells broke up
yeah so the phone cards it's a big
business and you're switching to
long-distance service you use a t well
i'm working for this company
representing them we could save you 20
30 and i'm going to make a commission of
up to 30 percent on your remember the
company names jerry communications got
it i remember quest was doing it too
right that's what's going on
first yeah there was a few lcp
which became no i'm sorry uh
i forgot what it was but that became a
publicly traded new york stock exchange
stock it was a hot sector
so this is what i chose to participate
in
so when i get home i'm looking for bank
i'm looking for you know somebody to
stake me
and a buddy of mine who was the nephew
of a gangster by the name of john
gamarano he approaches me saying look my
uncle will put this up because he's a
pretty popular guy a strong businessman
strong wise guy well he's not a wise guy
but he's not a maid guy but he's a
gangster his name is joe watts and joe
white is making a fortune in this my
uncle wants to put you two together so i
meet with john gamarano joe watts i go
over this whole business model of what
i'm looking to do joe watson's making a
fortune with the phone cards
so
johnny gamarano agrees to stake me
he does we open up the office i start
doing well
johnny had always assumed that one way
or another i would go back to wall
street in one capacity or another so now
the most interesting part of this in the
trajectory of my life
is now when i return home
less than three years later
everybody's a stock broker all of bay
ridge
all the bensonhurst
everybody's a broker and everybody is
making a fortune off this new invention
called the world wide web this is
92.99
94.95 so now
it's the start or the advent of the
internet
guys are making a killing so this is
when all of these firms
popped out of the woodwork and everybody
was making a fortune
now i'm still relegated to doing the
long distance service i got a nice
business i'm starting to ramp up but the
itch to get back to wall street was
always there
so then my original partner howard appel
the guy from philadelphia tells me about
this one stock that he's working it's
called nal financial and it's backed by
even wayne heisenga here in florida who
at the time was the chairman and the
founder of blockbuster video very
wealthy guy so i think one of the
reasons why i was able to stay under the
radar for so long patrick is because we
always did quality deals like investors
always had a shot there were nobody
there was no customer complaints and if
nobody's complaining we're not on the
radar so with that said we did this nal
financial deal and this was a hot deal
so my job was to find stock brokers to
promote it and then additionally i can
compensate them under the table in cash
and we got off again
so now it's may of 1995. i have a
wedding to pay for that's when my wife
and i were married i needed money i
needed to jump back into this universe
and now i'm noticing all this mob
influence on wall street you had so many
wise guys involved who had a piece of
this what a piece it is what a piece of
this any big names or no uh yeah you had
uh
like
it's probably better for me if i don't
get that specific if you don't mind what
were they bosses involved the
underbosses involved like the high
that were involved in this the money was
too good not to and let me just say
something the mob has always been on
wall street it may be different capacity
i don't care if you know they they find
a box of zero coupon bonds but the point
is the mob has always had an influence
on wall street not to this degree but
the mob has always been there even today
how can i vouch for what happens today
right you know
but the mob is my assumption is yes if
there's money to be made on wall street
particularly
particularly you know when you can
corrupt the broker or too
you know
makes sense
okay so
so now this is my first deal and we make
big money right off the bat this is the
nil n-e-l n-a-o and a-l
so now a buddy of mine my best friend
from my whole life who's working at
gruntal okay
grundle decides to make a market meaning
they're going to support and trade nao
financial that's how legit this stock
was this is no penny stock
so i grabbed joe i said listen your
firm's already in this
why don't you get out of there
i'll stake it we'll open up a broken
dealer under you
and you know with these internet stocks
and some of the deals that howard and i
are working on we can make an absolute
fortune
after a lot of coaching and explaining
he finally agrees so now i have my hands
on a brokerage firm
now there's a lot of heat there's a lot
of pressures a lot of investigation so i
don't want to put a bullseye on my
forehead by owning a broken dealer so i
decide to go the franchise route again
the way i did earlier on by owning the
franchise you take a lot of the the
watchful eyes of the regulators and the
scrutiny off yourself and it's more on
corporate so we did a couple of deals it
was a company called argent securities
out of atlanta jp turner securities
shamrock partners we were able to keep
changing the name on the door to avoid
any kind of you know heat or problems do
quality deals
not be the direct owners of the firm so
the regulatory scrutiny goes to
corporate and we were able to capture a
run and the kind of deals we did were
insane i remember this one deal
it was called metro media china
when i started on wall street in 1985
there were four billionaires in the
world that's it just four billionaires
number four on that list was a guy by
the name of john kluge john kluge was
the chairman of metro media
now we owned a shell company that was
already in china and john kluge's team
was trying to get to china to build out
the cable infrastructure there he
couldn't get in there without buying
something that was already that he could
be more or less grandfathered in
so now we're in bed with the fourth
richest man in the world
ultimately we put up like let's say a
million bucks of cash raised 10 million
from the public he put up a ton of money
the deal ends up blowing up china throws
all foreign ownership out of the country
howard appel calls me one morning he
says listen we're still getting [ __ ]
we're just getting [ __ ] by better
quality people
that's the phone call
we're still getting [ __ ] we're just
getting [ __ ] by better quality people
again the guy's the fourth richest
billionaire in the world so we always
did quality deals so even though that
one didn't work out i mean you want to
talk about a shot that we had there you
talk about building out the cable
infrastructure in the country
so we always did quality deals and we
were able to capture or run as a result
but what made me really deadly and this
was probably the separator from let's
say me and a strategy
is when you do this i mean this is a
criminal enterprise
you're never going to trust everybody or
trust anybody a hundred percent but
there has to be some sort of trust i'm
paying you cash in a bag and charging
you and going out and soliciting this
stock so how do you get these
co-conspirators patrick how do you
develop these people well
you have a lot of wise guys that have a
lot of kids around them and they have a
lot of wannabe gangsters and this was
their way in by getting license or
paying another individual to take the
series seven for them which became very
popular and now they're told to play
ball with zao
so now i have the mob recruiting the
brokers for me because nobody was ever
going to shake me down i wasn't going to
pay protection money per se that wasn't
me although i knew i needed protection
you can't run this enterprise but i was
too much of an ego too much of an
egomaniac to say hey i need protection
let me pay you scratch your ass produce
something for me well recruit brokers
and i'll give you a piece so if i'm
paying the broker twenty percent i'm
gonna pay the wise guys ten percent i'm
gonna slowly move up the ranks i'm a guy
that can keep his mouth shut i don't
fear jail
i can handle myself i have the brains i
have the work ethic this is a perfect
marriage this was the way it all began
what kind of money did you start making
at that time when you say start or
finish i mean i'm just giving you the
finish what were you at the end what was
your biggest year was 99 i made 30
million you're net at 30 million and 99
it's always net it's green yeah
that is the number that matters so
you're making 30 and
99 and and what's i mean at that point
is this when you're living in your 5
million home you got 2 million dollars
of you're trying to figure out a place
where to hide the cash and that's in
other words knowing that there's no way
in the world this was going to last my
play and what was in my head is
diversification diversification
diversification so i spread it out all
over the place five million dollar
excuse me uh four million dollars in
restaurants real estate all under other
people's names so i was big with cash
businesses and a lot of businesses i
don't care if it was a beauty parlor or
a piece of career
every laundry everything so my point is
i know ultimately this is going to end
so you're going to bring 2000 a week to
my wife you're going to bring 5 000 a
month to my wife you're bring two
thousand a day to my wife knowing that i
had to spread around the plan was that
if something happened to me she would be
well provided for i paid cash for my
home the home wasn't under me or the
business so you know i did it i made
enough moves
where i was trying to at least be able
to provide for them if something bad
happened for me and then along the way
you know we just started doing more and
more deals and we started getting more
and more popular and you know you
mentioned the paul anka thing before and
yeah i mean it was just a crazy what was
it like what was uh are you partying
hard are you having fun what are you
guys doing i'm in my life of course
we're partnering with some stories what
were some of the things you guys were
doing i mean you know
i'm hearing the story about 50 60 000 of
cash being thrown at strip clubs what
were some of the things that were
happening that was a stereotype for the
broker during the time that was never my
thing
so what did you get how did you guys
party
well
you know one of the things i felt
responsible for and this probably an
illustration of how crazy i am i got
involved in the boxing promotion
business
and i wanted to be the biggest and best
promoter in the world but i felt almost
charged with the responsibility of
bringing it back to the wise guys
bringing it back to the italians which
hasn't had a foothold on on boxing since
probably the early 1960s
so with that said i i invested in a
promotion company and then i really
worked it in other words we had some
famous fighters we had eric harding who
fought roy jones jr for the light
heavyweight championship that was roy's
last fight under his hbo agreement this
is when roy was still roy i had james
tony i had mitch blood green who fought
tyson we had bernard hopkins but i i
opted not to sign him so i mean this was
my thing so this was a passion play and
this is how i end up meeting paul anger
because what happened was i signed an
agreement with espn where i was their
exclusive espn2 friday night fights that
was my show so we would travel all over
the country in these boxing matches so
my casino host at the mirage was steve
wynn's sister-in-law it was steve wynn's
wife's sister her name was marianne
she introduced me to paul anka paul paul
and i struck up an immediate friendship
and relationship and then paul brings me
a deal that to this day i'm sick to my
stomach that i passed on and i'll tell
you that funny story he tells me he says
now i own an entertainment company which
we'll get to shortly but he says listen
he says i got a kid i want to sign the
kid he's got no money
he needs quick cash so why don't you and
i former production company so he comes
up with the name ranca productions which
is a derivative of romano and anchor so
we formed that company with his attorney
whose name was stuart silfen very famous
entertainment attorney i have no
attorney coverage in this deal at all
and i'm looking at the agreement and
it's this thick anyway the plan was and
david foster was not famous the way he
is today but david foster had an
agreement with sony where they were
gonna sign him to a two album deal and i
could get my money back almost
immediately so i said well how much we
have to put into it and he said it's
like 400 grand so i said let me hear the
cd so he plays me this cd it's michael
buble
he plays me the cd
so i said i don't know paul i mean you
know big band music
i mean
he said so i'm telling you the guy's
just like harry connick jr it's okay do
we really need another harry connick
junior ball
listen to me if there's one thing i know
paul's music this guy's got no shot
he'll never make it
make a long story that's a joke but i
never said that make a long story show
when i'm reviewing the contract it's me
putting up 400 grand he doesn't have one
quarter in this yeah so anyway i
supported a pass on this deal he loses
his mind hates my guts as a result
that deal blows up and michael buble
becomes what michael boy is today i was
listening to michael buble last night
putting my daughter down i was she
wanted to listen to christmas song so i
played a michael buble christmas song
he's got the he's got a very unique
voice how do you think we had a market
for him
paul sang the song right sounds sounds
way he did something for like opening up
one of your businesses i don't know what
it was
this was my get out deal and we had a
launch party and we brought him in just
to sing it so he changed the lyrics to
uh knob sorry he changed yeah he changed
the lyrics of my way he made it sal's
way sal's way so so let's go back to the
mob so you're doing stuff with you you
get introduced through john
uh johnny g gamorano and then from there
something happens to john i think he
goes away and then you get hooked up
with mikey scars what happens to you
walk me through this so cause mikey
scars was a cowboy right he was
accomplished yes
there was some stories about him
potentially he was lined up to be the
next boss yeah that came a few years
later after he and i were extremely
close which we would not at this time
but gamorano is my guy
so basically as johnny's under
indictment the entire time that i
initially met him so i'm living in the
halfway point when you guys met out the
marriott and then he met him right okay
they're very good by the way
with your research the day i meet him
he's under indictment in louisiana
and i'm in a halfway house so i'm still
in the bureau of prison's custody i'm
living in bedfordstein brooklyn at a
halfway house and he and i have our
first meeting and he approached me like
look i heard you're a big money maker
you know what you're doing you're your
kid to keep his mouth shut i checked you
out even going to the guys in the
midwest they have nothing but great
things to say about you
i want you to meet joe watson we'll get
hooked up with this so ultimately we do
but then when i'm doing the wall street
gig now they're one problem after
another that i got to keep bringing him
into so now he's involved in pretty much
everything i'm doing the problem that he
makes his mistake is now he's going away
and he doesn't tell anything about tell
anybody about anything he's doing with
me at all which is a cardinal mistake
his contention was he invested his own
money in this legitimate enterprise and
he doesn't have to explain it or report
to anybody god okay that was a cracker
[ __ ] it might have been your own money
but you can't have a more illegal
enterprise that i'm running in fact
robin morgenthau manhattan district
attorney said if this firm did anything
legitimate it was by accident
so everything was
that was his quote if this firm did
anything legitimate was by accident wow
now i would challenge the statement but
it is what it is that was it so now
mikey mikey scarce comes in no it's not
that simple patrick back up
so now john you're teasing us he's
teasing us with mike well i'll get to it
so john tell i said john what do i do
with you going away i mean we've got
peeps every day there's another problem
here i mean look at the way we live our
lives i mean this is not going to be
kept quiet he says okay he says there's
a guy in staten island which i don't
want to mention his name he's still very
active today you see him if there's any
problem i said okay
then he comes back to me says don't see
him do you know who mikey scars is i
said yes i do he said do you know him i
said no
he says maybe you see him then he comes
back another day and he says you're not
going to see him
just see my nephew
i said just see your nephew
you know if he's not even a street guy
how's that going to help me
what does that mean
anyway he leaves it like that with me
so of course as predicted we have 20
problems the minute he leaves because
everybody's around and everybody's
ironing it everybody's doing something
there's going to be a lot of beats as a
result
so now i have an issue
what the nephew decides to do
is rather than put it on reggie with our
family the gambinos he goes to the
bananas
because he's got a friend there to try
to represent this
so now i'm like are you out of your mind
it don't work that way you're gonna
create problems for your uncle problems
for me this is crazy but he stayed
pretty steadfast with that okay
so now
i'm at a firm and that firm is doing an
initial public offering okay there's an
ipo coming
and
actually let me back up
so now with that said i try to sever
myself a little bit from that problem
because i know this kid just made a
major mistake you don't go to another
family that was a mistake
so at this point
michael sends two guys to come see me
two guys that i know very very well made
men or no uh one to me guy one is a
associate associate yeah
big guy though
so i meet them at a restaurant right
next to my office they called me and
when they called me i said who is this
and they uh said it's heckle and jekyll
or whatever stupid name they use so they
said we're next door at the restaurant
come see us so i go there and there's a
vestibule there
and in the vest of you we don't actually
go in the restaurant and one of them
says listen you guys are doing an ipo
that ipo has got to come here it's got
to beat us i said well the ipo is not
going to you it's going to johnny he
said you can't do that i said listen to
me johnny's writing me letters he's
calling my house he's telling me i got
to be strong he's only as strong as his
friends are on the street i can't give
you this he said well this is going to
be a problem so i said well i don't know
what you want to do you want to roll
around right here in the vestibule
you're not getting it i don't know what
you want to do but you're not getting it
that night i go to a club in uh bay
ridge brooklyn
michael's at the bar and i went there
specifically to see maybe he'd be around
i was going to approach him but i knew
he'd approach me
so he sends one of the guys that i saw
in a vestibule over to see me and he
says michael won't stop you so i see
michael at the bar this is 1996 and he
says you're crazy man you go to see my
two thugs like that my goons and you
tell them what you told you don't need
to see anybody else you're with me you
just see me
like you think this guy johnny could
help let me know this is leonardo this
is okay number one he's old number two
he's not well liked number three's a
drunk number four when he comes home
he's moving to florida you know he can't
do anything who's the time of moving to
florida johnny toronto okay johnny yeah
so now i got a skipper
telling me i'm directly with him
so i got to make a decision
how much more loyalty can i continue to
support johnny g with now that michael
himself is telling me this so i'm going
to guys that i respect their opinion
wise guys what do i do everybody's
saying you don't understand michael he's
going to be a boss one day you're in
great shape this guy's going to be a
boss you're doing the right thing but
now technically i'm betraying gamorano
which i'm very uncomfortable about am i
willing to die over it i don't maybe i
mean i love the life i wanted to be part
of his life this was made for me and i
didn't want to answer to anybody so i
had very lofty goals i didn't want to be
a skip around to be boss
i mean
100 italian doesn't matter for you you
don't even have to be 100 italian your
father has to be italian they changed it
yeah it used to be the mother could
pretty much be anything and your father
has to be attacked
at the time okay so you're okay so i
thought it was 100 cecilia my point is i
don't take orders very well but i'm
going to be in this i want to run it
were you really ambitious enough to one
day want to be a boss or no
if it was there for the taking yes i
would have okay because i i think i
understand the biggest mistake the mob
ever made the biggest mistake ever
besides the fact that there's no loyalty
and there's just
they made such a mess of it
the problem is if they ever ever
really implemented then this is supposed
to be organized crime i mean look how
organized it was with maya lansky and
lucky luciano so you know everybody says
when gotti came it's because paul was a
businessman paul was a businessman he
didn't know the street first of all of
course paul knew the straight he was
indicted and did time for hijacking so
don't say he wasn't a straight guy maybe
you know he forgot those roots and he
became a businessman but that's exactly
what was needed without a doubt a
businessman not nobody was flipping at
the time how do you explain that so what
happened is now with the new regime
nobody's providing for these families so
if patrick is going to go away for sal
that sal better do the right thing for
patrick's family and with nobody doing
that and nobody implementing that and
instilling those values and you're left
for the philistines why would you stay
loyal why why would you
so you understand merta was impossible
in my world this and i'm going to use
the word conformity a lot
if are you familiar with joe valachi of
course okay so joe village he lets he
was the first rat sure but what joe
valachi did is he gave mario puzo and
francis ford coppola the platform to
understand a world they never would have
understood
and because of all that information out
there from velocity now puzzle's able to
write a book
so once francis ford coppola comes into
this mix and he's such a family-oriented
guy he brings the family element into
organized crime in the mafia and what
happens is everybody wants to be part of
this so the the wise guys may have not
acted yeah the way
the way marlon brando acted now they
wanted to act that way so you want to
talk about art imitating life or life
imitating heart there's the reason so
now you have a whole new spectrum of
what this is supposed to be about but
everybody forgets this patrick so let me
remind you of something there was no
federal presence there was no fed
investigation
as early as 1960 you have j edgar hoover
stating publicly there's no such thing
as them
so if you're relegated to local cops you
keep them on the payroll you stay off
the radar it was pretty easy then once
rudy starts bringing in you know
the ricoh act and now you have that he
changed the game though
before him bobby kennedy really did too
because now all of a sudden there was an
attack on the mob
and the only reason in my world why
bobby kennedy ever went after the mob
was to keep it quiet about how his
brother became president there's a lot
of different speculations there there's
a lot of different speculations there
because of all
situation would they they were worried
about illinois with dewey they needed
those seven thousand votes from dead
people
west virginia they really didn't need
illinois by the way that was going to
happen without it and then they hated
the fact that there was that uh you
always a favorite type of mentality and
bobby had the bigger ego than john
apparently
uh but at the same time there's a little
bit of link with the marilyn monroe and
women and sonny there's a lot of
different stories to it but but the
point is once the attack on the mafia
started now
and it's publicity now and it's
publicity nobody needed it and joe
bonanno's book also didn't help by the
way he wrote that book that joe colombo
with his italian civil rights campaign
and then of course john in 1985 so what
shot did this have so if it's going to
be an imminent prison sentence for
everybody provide for the families do
you think guys are flipping because
they're afraid of jail these guys these
are men interesting nobody's afraid of
jail they're afraid of not providing for
their family so if you and that was one
of mikey scars concerns as well when he
talked about in the interview with
trevor mcdonald he says i called the
guys i'm like wait a minute i need food
for my wife for my wife and the boss
said
get her on uh welfare because she needs
to get on so let me get her on welfare i
can't get her on welfare and then that's
when he flipped they showed that in good
fellows too yeah so the concern is if
you can't support your family the person
is going to flip
well that's just one you know part of it
did you follow tommaso boshiro's story
as well or no
similar story there as well slightly
different there because of uh
you know the point is a wise guy takes
an oath to put this okay cos an
australia yeah ahead of god and their
own family i mean only an imbecile would
actually do that you may make that
profession at your induction ceremony
but do you think anybody really believes
that do you want to put this thing
because ahead of your child ahead of
your god
i mean what's that gonna get you so it's
a fake statement to begin with but my
point is if they ever implemented
something to provide for the families
and how would they have to be a formula
you know based on your contributions
earnings based on where you were still
somebody still would have flipped them
without a doubt yeah but my point is it
would have been less i think it would
have been contained no it would have
been less okay so now you you get with
mikey scars they tell you he's going to
be the boss he's a couple at that time
you're going in is this still 99 when
you're netting 30 or would you resist
with mikey starts 96
so now it's 97 and the fbi comes to my
house knocks on the door six o'clock in
the morning and has two agents there and
they tell me i'm going to be
assassinated they tell me there's a
contract on my life and it's coming from
the west side which is the genovese
family so i said can you tell me why and
they were like we don't know anything
about you
we just obligated to tell you this from
informants there's contract on your life
from the west side i said and you can't
tell me anything he said supposedly some
stock deal that went bad so i said well
i'm not involved in stocks so i don't
even know what you're talking about they
said look we're just giving you the
heads up
so obviously i took this as a credible
threat so in my mind i believe this is
gamorano
from prison got it plotting to kill me
knowing he can't use the gambino family
to kill me so he had to go to the west
side that's what i believe now
so now i have a choice do i sit inside
like a hermit do i change my lifestyle i
didn't even move into my new house yet
and i only had i had two children they
were babies and i'm still on parole i
got a probation officer an answer to so
now i call her and i tell her i guess
i'm obligated to tell you this but the
fbi just left here telling me i'm going
to be killed
she said well if you have any problems
you know my number i'm licensed to carry
a firearm great
so now i'm left saying what do i do now
so obviously i go to michael i explained
to him what's going on and i said would
you think i was crazy if i told you i
think it was gamorano he says no i
wouldn't think you're crazy i think
you're very very smart you've come a
long way in these last few years
and we were left to believe that so yeah
i guess this is when i started realizing
you know i don't want to say how tough i
am
but yeah at the end of the day i wasn't
going to change anything i made the
decision that this is my life that i am
in this i'll do what i can to protect
myself i have my crew i'll do whatever i
can but i'm not going to change anything
and again i hadn't even moved into my
home yet i hadn't even bought the new
brokerage firm that i was going to buy
and this was just really at the start
so we got off we did deal after deal i
did all of these other businesses things
were going very very well
and then pete gotti gets pinched in
2002 at some point
and then at my restaurant we're having a
birthday party for michael i want to say
that was june 2002
after michael left his party he arrived
home and i think at five o'clock in the
morning that morning he got picked up
and pinched so now he was arrested too
so now ironically enough at the time
where michael
is now in jail camarado's now back on
the street
so where do you think that leaves me
and this is where everybody betrays me
i get bounced around from guy to guy
nothing but issues nothing but problems
9 11 happened the internet bubble in
march of 2000 happen things are no
longer robust and good and now
camarado's playing his games and now
this is when everything goes bad and
then ultimately in may of 2003 is when i
agreed to flip
okay so at this point a bunch of stuff
is happening
you're getting to a point where you're
gonna have to cooperate because you know
gamorano is coming out yeah
you're worried what's going to happen if
he comes out this is you said 0203 it's
right after 9 11. it's o203
so but pre talking about what happens
when you cooperate
when you're making 30 a year i'm
assuming you're probably partying with
the best of the best i'm assuming you
have some stories i'm assuming you're on
celebrities i'm assuming you know you
probably are being invited to some
exclusive parties what was the life like
at the time yeah well with the boxing
company which was really my baby you
know that's what i guess gave me you
know a platform to do other things you
know we were in negotiations for about
six months with sugar ray leonard's
company he had formed sugary leonard
boxing and he was throwing his hat in
the ring with promotion firm as well so
we had a few meetings with him we hit it
all very very well and then that became
meeting with tommy hearns
and
and his management to try to acquire the
cronk name out of detroit croc boxing we
were negotiating with them
simultaneously we had acquired the
rights i signed the license agreement to
gleason's gym in brooklyn and we had
opened up an additional like a satellite
operation of gleason's in long island
where we had gleasons too so what we
were utilizing this for was a stable of
bringing up young upcoming fighters we
could keep a pulse on them we could
bankroll them finance them try to you
know be instrumental in their careers so
you know during that and you know doing
a lot of traveling to vegas southern
california uh the foxwoods in
connecticut you know we were always
hobnobbing with a lot of celebrities so
joe montana had approached the associate
of mine where he was doing a lifestyle
magazine called joe montana's in the red
zone which was a lifestyle sports
magazine what year is this this was
97 i want to say is he still playing for
the chiefs he's not no he's no longer
what he's done yeah he's done so he came
to me came to our office and we had
acquired
i want to say probably upwards of 50 of
the rights to that magazine
so the magazine had launched we had run
you know two consecutive months it did
pretty well
and then essentially paul anka had
introduced me to a guy by the name of
bernie hewman bernie human only managed
he was a manager he only managed two
acts in his entire life
muhammad ali and siegfried and roy wow
and he's the one that landed sig freedom
roy that big deal at the mirage
paul anka's best friend is steve nguyen
the owner of the murrah
so when at the time when we did the
montana magazine we wanted to approach
ali we wanted to try to do something
with ali
now anka had had his own vision in mind
what he wanted to do was because of the
relationship with bernie human and
the mirage as well as you know his
intimate information on the rat pack and
the special effects that they utilize
for siegfried and roy paul anka wanted
to do this entire show where he brings
back the rat pack back to life to
i guess with holograms to perform with
him utilizing the special effects
of siegfried and roy
so bernie human agreed to me with me we
met at the four seasons in manhattan and
we and we were trying to get that show
off the prerequisite that i gave and i
said you got to give me ali everybody
told me that ali was untouchable you
could never get to ali that he'll never
do anything
with that said bernie was able to get me
ali and we did the muhammad ali i think
it was for his 50th birthday at the time
the commemorative special magazine for
his 50th birthday which was coming out
simultaneously with the release of will
smith's film ali so we had that deal in
the pipeline today do these guys did
montana did i ali did their camp i don't
know that you're an associate with the
gambino family i don't think initially
but
over time yes because paul agger
absolutely did it's one of the reasons
why i fell in love with me in other
words anchor was a kid when i say kid he
was in his mid-20s to early 30s during
the time of the rat pack but they took
him under his wing i mean he wrote songs
for sammy davis he wrote my way for
sinatra so anchor would be out there
legend i mean he's
so he saw us me and my crew
in reverse in other words now he was
sinatra and we were the young guys
around him and that's what he loved so i
traveled all over the country with him
in other words we either promoting
boxing matches or hanging with him he
was going through a pretty ugly divorce
at the time which nobody knew about so
he was traveling with his girlfriend you
know i mean he let me into that world
and i became very very close but as a
result i was forming a sports media
entertainment company that i was
ultimately going to take public and i
made him you know like an advisory board
member and then ultimately the ceo of
the advisory board so he was able to
bring me a lot of properties and
ordinarily
he wasn't a shareholder he was a warrant
holder warren hold okay there's this he
did not own stock but he don't want it's
protected if it's warranted so it's it's
slightly different than having shares so
when i knew that the heat was on me and
the pressure was coming what i decided
to do was take all of these properties
that i owned anything that could be
deemed media entertainment leisure and
even roll up the restaurants that i had
into a publicly traded show i bought a
company called jaguar investments i had
35 million shares jaguar was trading at
six dollars a share and this was my get
out deal so now this is after the
internet bubble which hurt us greatly in
march of 2000 we're entering 2001. i
needed
we had more properties we had a grease
remake starring britney spears and
justin timberlake in the year 2000 when
nobody even knew who these kids were so
they were they were they were get out of
here they weren't popular yet but they
were known so we had we had justin
timberlake and britney spears signed to
do a grease remake one
we had a contract with nbc to do the
first reality golf circuit tournament
which at the time the only reality show
out at the time was survivor so nbc
loved this model we had the rights to
john travolta's next three films we
bought a small production company a guy
by the name of jonathan crane and he had
the rights to travel this next three
films this is at a time where he had
just released swordfish just to put a
timeline to it
so we had what we deemed you like
swordfish that was all right
i'm with you go ahead that would have
been the first film we did so at this
point you're worth about a quarter of a
billion
if you take thirty five times six that's
210. but that's without all the other
assets remember i owned a brokerage firm
that managed a half a billion dollars at
your peak what was your net worth
actually i don't know i don't know it's
too fragmented yeah i mean if you go the
value of the brokerage firm and all the
paper that i own i mean at one point we
had done four penny stocks literally
pennies
in in january of 2000 all four of them
were trading north of 30
a share a penny stock to 30 yeah i mean
because they were all technology driven
and now
i mean we bought the uh the yahoo ipo
was up 100 points in one day this was a
crazy time so it was so hard for me to
qualify it or quantify the amount it
really was it was very difficult makes
sense why didn't you go legit though why
why didn't you go i was planning to with
this premiere deal but i waited till you
know the heat got to the point where it
was inevitable that i was do you think
you think you would ever go legitimately
you know how everybody says i was
planning like you know the movie what's
that one movie i love them with
carlito's way where he gets i said i'm
not doing that you know i'm not doing
this and then he's taking his nephew the
nephew gets shot up at this one bar and
he's like well you know one day we're
gonna go live i'm telling you we're
gonna go live this place and then you
know benny blanco from the bronx shows
up at the end says hey remember me benny
blanco from the bronx everybody says
they're going to leave but are you
really going to leave their life patrick
here's the way i'll frame it to you okay
in all honesty yeah because i'm probably
the biggest hypocrite in the world in
other words i believed i was somewhat
legit i did quality companies people
were making money there were no victims
it's not like we were robbing pension
funds and widows or
bernie madoff with a ponzi scheme i wore
a suit and die every day i got in
earlier than anybody i stayed later and
i worked and i tried to develop the
crimes that were guilty of
enterprise corruption racketeering money
laundering bribery the furtherance of
organized crime tax evasion all guilty
as charged but i could always shave my
own face in the mirror and sleep soundly
at night because i never robbed people
that wasn't my game we weren't doing
fake companies and hurting the public
there were no victims at the time the
only time that victims developed and
there was a manisterfation of it but the
only time that manifested into victims
was after the internet bubble in in
march of 2000 because whenever they came
crashing down as well as the heat so
this enterprise this premier sports
media and entertainment group that i
tried to do tried to build would have
been the get out deal but the mob was
still a very very strong hold in my life
if i was going to be in this i was going
to try to be boss so to say legit now i
never thought about going legit because
the mob was always a big stronghold on
me did you ever have any direct dealings
with any of the bosses or no
yeah louis they don't he was the boss of
little casey acting boss of the lucasy
family he was a very very dear friend
when we did the full angle launch party
he grabbed my mother pulled her aside he
said your son mrs romano is a rose among
thorns and i'll never forget him saying
that wow and then he grabbed michael and
he said michael when are you going to
straighten this kid out if you don't
make him i am so yeah i was very liked
and and louie i did a lot of business
well i did some business with i
shouldn't say a lot mostly moving money
around and i loved him to death he's
doing life sentence now in louisburg i
believe or allah would excuse me so 03
you decide to cooperate what happens
next when you decide to cooperate
no you're never forced i made a decision
but i was greatly betrayed and that's
what encouraged my thinking to cooperate
michael had already flipped and i knew
michael uh you know reluctantly would
have to tell them everything about me
i knew i had an investigation that was
ramping up for the district attorney's
office in manhattan so i knew i had
state problems i knew i had fed problems
and i knew the heat was closing in on me
i would have done my time i never in a
million years would have agreed to
cooperate what really encouraged my my
thought process on cooperating is the
betrayal in other words i was doing
business with a very famous producer
who's also one of the largest real
estate holders in the united states and
he's about two blocks south of here so
unfortunately i don't want to get into
his name but he's a big guy
and he was corrupt and we were doing a
lot of things together
and that being said
he was in bed with another fella and i
will mention that name a guy by the name
of eli weinstein that name meant nothing
to me had no idea who that is
anyway
i met with a skipper in the gambino
family capo who pulled me in and said
you're doing business with this norton
herrick guy
so i said yeah he just gave me a six
million dollar mortgage on my house in
other words i had paid cash for my house
and when i knew the heat was coming in
this was a good time to pull money out
of it
so i said yeah i'm doing a lot of
business with him he's got like 10
million to cash up with me he just gave
me six million from my house he said
okay he says he's got something that
this eli weinstein wants
we need you to go to him and tell him to
give eli weinstein back everything
i said how do you even know who this guy
is and how are you putting him with me
what do you know
i had another meeting and a guy had
another wise guy and that guy had a
post-it a little yellow posted and it
said the name of this producer
and he said sal i want to talk to you
about this guy i said you're another one
what do you guys have to do with my guy
he's mine how does anybody even know
this guy exists
so does eli weinstein give it back tell
him to give it back to him okay i go to
this guy and i said look this is what
i've been told you know who i am
you got to give blah blah you got to
give it back to him he says i'm not
doing anything without me talking to my
guy and my guy's in chicago i said well
you're going to have to give me your
name
so we can make our people talk to him
anyway to make a long story short
i was then
met with the same cabo
and he said sal you know this guy that
you're shaking down for all this money
back the [ __ ] off him
what the hell are you talking about now
you're protecting him
are you guys crazy what are you talking
about now you fast forward to today
today
the last order of business that donald j
trump did as president united states is
he granted a presidential pardon to eli
weinstein who received a 20-year
sentence for embezzling 300 million
dollars from the jewish community of
people he saw every day so if trump
wanted to commute a sentence you'll do
that for somebody that's wrongfully
accused you know harshly judged or a
myriad of reasons that you could justify
this guy embezzled 300 million dollars
from his community and got a
presidential pardon as a result he did
six years on a 25 or 30 year sentence
that when he was out on bond he
committed a further crime and robbed 45
million dollars regarding an investment
in facebook while he was out on bond
trump excuse me he did not give him a
pardon he commuted a sentence down to an
immediate release and that was the last
order of business that trump did as he
was walking out the door who the hell is
this guy
no nothing
all i know is that's that's what my
research showed as early as a week ago
that's insane what what a connection of
the stories and by the way if you're
saying the big producer
real estate i mean you pretty much gave
them away maybe it's
the name but that's a whole different
story i won't say the name i'll say the
name go forward norton herrick okay you
knew that
if you're saying here local yeah
so
it's not going to be hard to figure that
part out but anyway so i was doing a ton
of business he was one of my largest
investors i mean we had a lot of you
know we had paul de jouria who's the
owner of paul mitchell
we had the bellsburg family up in canada
the seagram's family i mean this is the
kind of money that we were around so we
always did legit deals and that's why i
was able to stay under the watchful eye
of the regulators for so long these are
the type of deals we did but this norton
herrick guy i mean there's a patrick it
would take me three hours to explain
that story he and i were joined at the
hip he had a publicly treated company i
was working it from time to time he
asked me to drive the price down
of his publicly traded company the
reason for that is
things were it was a tumultuous market
he believed the banks would give him
more favorable rates if they believe
that he was imminently looking to file
chapter so i mean this goes on and on
and on and then i recorded tape
conversations of him i was trying to
extort him to get the deed to my home
back he ran and the guys that were with
me or i was with are now betraying me
for him and it goes on and on like that
everybody betrays everybody in that
world
it's a very uh
the only guy that from uh i had a
meeting with sunny francis
i don't know if you know what you of
course you know michael's father
standing friends
at a meeting with uh sonny three times
we met because i was trying to do the
interview and every time no
last time i went out there we took a
crew of five of us six of us camera and
i took him to an italian restaurant i'm
driving him to the town university it's
102 years old we're moving them with a
wheelchair but the guy had the energy of
a 20 year old he could talk
so what do you think about such and such
great guy what do you think about lucky
he's your error you're from his era
fantastic guy what do you think about
ben siegel great guy how about meyer
great family guy who is meyer
billionaire i don't know what you're
talking about so so he was so he did 55
years yep in jail 55 years just because
he said this is the life i chose he
stuck to it and allegedly he was
innocent on that original church he was
innocent yeah he was innocent on that
well other things he was not but on that
one charge they got him they wanted to
kind of just violating yeah and then but
that but you know on that one charge yes
he he was innocent on that one charge so
all three you cooperate you chose to
at this point what happens to life from
o3 to today
did you stay low-key intentionally like
listen i'm just going to what did you do
for the opposite i you know i opened up
a legitimate they relocated me to
san diego california
uh
most of my partners were persian like
yourself they almost got to the point
where i could speak fluent farsi at this
point i mean everybody was iranian so i
did business with old persians 80
persian restaurants they staked me we
were able to get lucky with a couple of
companies and then you know again i'm
the luckiest guy in the world i'm living
in rancho santa fe california
and at the time oil is skyrocketing
right away i started investing in oil
and gas deals and then my partner who
went into the program with me
unfortunately he gets the bad luck of
being sent to des moines iowa well the
great thing about des moines iowa is
right now biodiesel and alternative
energy is in favor and he's in the corn
capital of the world so we were able to
invest wisely in energy and then hedge
wisely in alternative energy and we got
off we did very very very well again no
trouble since 03. yeah there's been
trouble nothing i want to talk about
this time but yes there's there's always
trouble the government is constantly
coming after me constantly so how do you
make money today are you fine right
right now you're low-key you're not
really doing anything business-wise
nothing that i would want to get into
publicly okay got it so just more
low-key today more so so so are we going
to see more of sal romano out there is
there going to be more stuff about you
out there are you more or less trying to
just
keep it low-key and you did this
interview just to do this interview no
absolutely not i've been asked to do
interviews for the last i don't know
close to 20 years constantly everybody
that ever heard my story says when are
you going to write a book when are you
going to write a book because i'm only
giving you a certain amount of
everything that i have in the arsenal
and i think right now with the situation
that i'm in it's about controlling the
narrative i don't want stories being
written about me or told without me at
least having a say in how it's framed
because i'll only frame the truth i'm a
devoted devoted devoted catholic
i love my faith i i pride myself on
being somewhat of a novice theologian
but i you know i my book is basically a
correlation of my spirituality and my
faith along with my past culmination to
where i'm at today in life so yeah
there's a story to tell and after many
years of contemplation i believe now is
the time to tell it and no better than
uh to launch with you sir well it's it's
great to have you on here i am sure this
is going to steer the pot with a lot of
different questions and comments and
people are going to reach out and
they're going to want to have you back
on to address other questions and maybe
we'll do a part two here
since we only had about 90 minutes here
together and i've really enjoyed talking
to you a unique story different angle
yeah it sounds like you were
one decision away from having been a
professional guy in the financial world
for decades and you would have made a
lot of money but that industry kind of
kept pulling you in because it sounds
like you had a little bit of aspirations
of wanting to be a boss there was
something very attractive
and i'm not a hypocrite i wanted that
life without a doubt i wanted that life
because if i wanted to go legit i could
have easily gone legit i had the talent
the work ethic and the brains right
you've done very brains yeah the brains
three times you talked about being at
the office at 7 45 and the way you
explained
you know blind pool the way you
explained the reverse you know that's
not something that everybody can explain
which means you know having started in
1985 with lemons for three years you
were with them it's not like you were
there for three or six months cold
calling for some other guy my first week
on the job lee iacocca was there leaving
ford trying to borrow to raise a billion
dollars from the company in order to
start a company called chrysler yeah
this was my first week on the job so yes
i've had the exposure of everything
no i was a baby but i was on premise
when he was there i mean he's a he's a
legend did you watch ford versus foreign
of course but you think about the story
in there with what he did with
negotiating with italy and enzo and all
that smart yeah crazy stuff anyway sal
thanks for coming out thanks for being
here sunday tim and i really it my
pleasure patrick
take care of it
anytime anytime completely different
perspective of that life sal romano how
he made his money and what happened to
by the way if you enjoyed this interview
give it a thumbs up and subscribe to the
channel i got two other videos i want
you to watch both podcasts that we
recently had on one is with samuel
garvano and the other one was michael
francis you're going to enjoy both of
them but click on one of these too if
you enjoyed this topic i think you'll
enjoy one of these two podcasts take
care everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you